this barren wasteland is one of the mine
dumps found in and around South Africa's
biggest city Johannesburg the soil here
is full of toxins like arsenic lead and
radioactive uranium the heavy rains and
dust storms that have become more
frequent in recent years have spread the
contamination
especially around Soweto and its
neighboring townships that's led Davila
Mokoena to become an environmental
activist educating people about the
health hazards posed by the mine dumps
she's invited us to a family home in
Soweto where her older sister and two
nephews live Davila knows that here
environmentalists use like climate
change are also social issues climate
change largely is viewed as an
environmental issue however it
encompasses everything it's a
developmental issue it's a it's a human
rights issue it's a social issues and
you find that when we look at the
impacts of climate change and how one
can adapt the most vulnerable are the
women and children
Divi Lee grew up under the racist
apartheid regime back then mining debris
was dumped directly next to the
townships where black people lived at a
safe distance from affluent white
suburbs as a young girl she saw how much
more vulnerable the poor and
disadvantaged were to environmental
problems women suffered doubly not only
were they exposed to the hazards in a
deeply entrenched patriarchal society
women have fewer choices and fewer means
to protect themselves that men could
dictate a woman's fate was a notion to
really grow up with traditionally you
know when a man gets married they're
looking to get a boy as a firstborn but
when I came out and they found that it's
a girl then my father said I've had
enough of kids that's the minimum of my
name Davila it means I've had enough
Davila was the third of four daughters
her father was a proud man who took good
care of his family yet he was also a
deeply traditional man he saw no value
in educating girls I thought I told my
mom did him he's not going to take again
to university because he feels he's
wasting his money because we will go to
school then start working but we'll be
working for another family because we'll
get married and work for someone else or
another feeling so he'll rather involved
invests in boys rather than in girls so
that things you know I think it sort of
inspired me to look into these gender
issues
Davi Lee did study anyway earning the
money she needed as a bank teller and
later as a marketer at a big national
newspaper she got more and more involved
in community work eventually she quit
her job and organized environmental
cleanup campaigns in Soweto
today Davila is the South Africa
coordinator for the gender into urban
climate change initiative the global
network evaluates and monitors the
gender components of climate protection
strategies in cities around the world
that a project workshop in Johannesburg
the coordinators share the experiences
and challenges faced by women in their
countries in India for instance many
poor families can't afford the security
of a basic life insurance Mumbai is of
course to Lydia
okay so fishing is a big industry there
so whenever the men go out to sea and
whenever there are storms and they don't
return back the women have either to
relocate or to look out for a different
business and to care for the family
themselves so the burden on them is
increased ten times more in South Africa
the initiative works together with two
cities swanny and Johannesburg Divi Lee
is especially interested in introducing
climate smart urban agriculture in
johannesburg Shubert park an abandoned
greenhouse has now become a community
garden the cooperative grows vegetables
and medicinal herbs currently the
project provides work for two formerly
jobless women two ladies the owner firm
in their area where they stay and then
they come here as volunteers to the
greenhouse to take care of their space
with the changing climate agricultural
practices have to change too the project
teaches women farmers how to adapt
sustainably in order to ensure income
and food security in the future so yeah
as we doing organic vegetables it helps
us to sustain ourselves because we sell
ours organic vegetables today local
market so we are able to have something
every week making themselves heard by
policymakers remains a big challenge the
city government had agreed to renovate
the greenhouse but cut the funding at
the last minute it's still a long way to
go but we will keep on raising our voice
and keep on commenting and critiquing
their their policies and make
recommendations identify gaps where
there are gifts it's work that takes
strength and perseverance and dávila
Mokoena
has plenty of both